you have a second child on the way soon
you have a son and so you're about to
have a daughter that's exciting
are you ready are you are you nervous
about it is anyone your so philosophical
now I know that's my yeah right now
you're like duality man if anybody
really ready you know what happened
after my son was born I was I was made
to face myself and I realized that I'm
actually a terrible person really
there's just more space for us to go to
grow and so that's where now I only
speak in the way that you're hearing me
which is like in these clips of
philosophical topic laundry's are you
bringing up are you gonna intend to
bring up both children with with certain
Korean traditions is that important yeah
I mean are they too weird
are the traditions both there's some
Korean traditions that are really funky
like you know I remember when I was a
kid if you wet the bed they would make
you put this like rice sifter on your
head or like a grain sifter I'm not sure
what it is and you would have to go to
the next-door neighbor and ask for salt
what this is it's just public shaming
that's what that is just public shaming
yeah how'd you persuade to get some
insult
that's I mean that that's it's so
specific
yeah there's no like weird Irish come
punishments yes being Irish is its see
that thing that comes up in the sky for
12 hours a day you're allergic to that
when you drink any alcohol you become an
[ __ ] Irish and on and on Irish and
Koreans are very similar that way
really yeah in in terms of all allergic
to the Sun right you know and we're also
heavy drinkers and we're that's a
deprecating we did some we did some
drinking in we didn't get crazy no no
but we saw some people get really crazy
yeah we watched them imbibe in nice
gnarly alcohol so what's the gnarly
alcohol there I can't really show you
yes yeah yeah yeah what's it made of
rice okay but that's that's fine yes
okay you don't seem to know much about
Korea guys